je pars odile je pars sans me retourner
non pas poil au nez meute esclaves pas
jeu par odile du pouf et bien pouf pouf
tu ne me crois pas mais je m'en vais
comme dit si bien verlaine au vent
mauvais plait-il odile mais quelle
explication il n'y a rien
d'extraordinaire
j'ai besoin de son souffle rauque sur ma
nuque embrasé maintenant j'ai besoin de
ses mains à la recherche de sonorités
nouvelles sur le clavier de messins se
dire j'y pensais encore ce matin mon
bureau crédit lyonnais
tout ce que je demande c'est de courir
nu sous une pluie fine sur la falaise
avec des grands chais mouillé c'est
pourtant simple vu qu'on s'abattent en
rien dans un champ de blé mûr et les 15
maires de vivaldi qui me tourner la tête
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise non
je ne renie pas le passé mais l'avenir
odile c'est sa jambe gauche quand elles
passent derrière mon dos pour que son
orteil touche mon oreille pendant un an
grâce à 3,60 droite contourne son genou
et vient s'enrouler autour de ce modèle
est-ce qu'il faut te faire un dessin
odile assaillent et le bureau des pleurs
maintenant mais il ne s'agit pas de
savoir si ça bouge en brasse
techniquement mieux
- bien que la tienne bon ses pieds sont
plus grands et alors ce n'est pas un
concours c'est une histoire comme il y
en a tous les jours je laime c'est tout
c'est classique et lui aussi il même
c'est la vie ça qu'est ce qui étonne
odile